here's black lesbian Corinne Jean-Pierre
who is the White House Press Secretary
being asked if she's worried that
there's some distance between the party
the Democratic party uh their messaging
on what's going on with the economy and
what's actually happening while an
Administration certainly has the
opportunity to celebrate achievements
like legislation is there any concern
that there's a dissonance between the
current economic moment and the kind of
Celebration you'll have this afternoon
on the south lawn about the inflation
reduction act when today's figures show
that inflation is still a great concern
when we talk about the Amtrak situation
and so forth is there a disconnect there
so I think if we look at the the picture
more broadly about what this means
because we have to remember the
inflation reduction Act is historic if
you think about how
um how elected
like the president and Democrats on
Congress other democrats for for decades
have been trying to fight big Pharma
have uh taking that to head for the last
last few decades to make sure that
Medicare that our seniors are able to um
to uh to not pay thousands of dollars a
month and that is a huge huge historic
uh historic win for the American people
it's not about us celebrating it's about
the win for the history for the American
and that's what you have seen when you
see costs that are going to come down
for our seniors when you see costs that
are going to come down for American
families as I just listed out for energy
costs are going to come down guys it
doesn't really matter what's happening
this is historic what we're doing here
it doesn't matter if the inflation
reduction act actually increased
inflation we're doing something historic
guys and also it says reduction in the
title of the thing it's the inflation
reduction act do I have to explain do we
have to carry the one for you people God
anyway all this being said I really you
know I one of the things that I really
want to focus on and that I thought
about a lot in August when I was off the
grid is I don't want to have blind spots
on these things and I don't want to be
in an echo chamber myself and I don't
want you guys to be in an echo chamber
and I know that that's extremely
difficult these days it really is when
one side is calling you fascists and
bigots and Nazis it's hard to kind of
keep reaching out to them it makes it
very difficult so I tweeted out
something this morning because I really
believe this I would love to find some
Biden supporters true Biden supporters
to have on the show because we are told
he got 81 million votes so there's got
to be a whole bunch of people out there
who really support this guy so here's my
tweet from this morning and it got a
bunch of traction and I will keep
checking the responses throughout the
day I said I'd love to have an avid
Biden supporter on the show someone who
truly believes Joe Biden is mentally fit
and healthy that his policies on economy
coveted immigration Etc are sound and
that he's moving America in the right
direction is there anyone so I saw
there's already a couple hundred
responses that on a quick lens I
couldn't really come up with anybody
like there I don't see anyone jumping at
it like a verified account that's really
saying it now we know that there are
certain media types that support him and
they're a Democrat just kind of democrat
operatives that's not who I'm talking
about I'm talking about like sort of
regular people uh I don't mean like just
the average Joe on the street but I'm
talking about people who know something
about politics who really think this
thing is working is they're an economist
who really thinks this working is there
anyone that really wants to defend him
on the covid policies and the mandates
and all of these things is there anyone
who really wants to go on the record and
say that they don't think there's
anything wrong with the guy I'm willing
to have this conversation I I truly
truly am